in this video we'll talk about the lipid
profile test and how to interpret the
report
your doctor might have prescribed a
lipid profile test and you see there are
different terminologies in that report
like ldl hdl vldl
and uh triglycerides
but how to interpret that result
so in this video we are going to break
down all of these things for you and
tell you the biology behind that
so this is a lipid profile test and you
can see
there are different test names in the
left hand side and there are
specific values provided on the right
hand side in unit of mg per deciliter
and also a normal range or a biological
range is provided but how to correlate
this data with a clinical condition or
how to analyze risk based on a report
all these things would be discussed in
this video so stay tuned till the end
so
in our body we have different
lipoprotein particles
they are named as kylo micron vldl idl
ldl hdl etc so all of these are
lipoprotein that that means they have
some amount of lipid and some amount of
protein and that is how our lipid is
transported across the body
in terms of composition all of these
lipoprotein particles differs from each
other for example chylomicron is highly
enriched in triglycerides
also vldl is highly enriched in
triglycerides
in contrast ldl is highly
concentrated with cholesterol particles
whereas in hdl the maximum portion is
the protein part
so
all of this
is secreted from the intestine liver or
maybe both
so your doctor
would say ldl is kind of like a bad
cholesterol whereas hdl is a good
cholesterol but do you know why so
is it true
but how
the primary function of ldl particle is
to provide cholesterol to the peripheral
tissue and it would be really useful
for
making hormones for example
your liver secretes ldl and that is
acting on or that is providing
cholesterol to testis or let's say
adrenal gland
so
in the adrenal gland using cholesterol
present in the ldl
all the adrenal steroid hormones would
be synthesized such as aldosterone
cortisol or
other hormones
in the testis as well your major male
steroid hormone testosterone would be
synthesized using cholesterol
so ldl derived cholesterol is super
important for normal biological
processes and function of the body so
ldl is damn important
but why does doctor call it bad
ldl is good but too much ldl is bad when
ldl is too much it deposits on the
artery wall and can create plugs and it
increases the risk of heart attack
now hdl is kind of involved in cleaning
up that block and it's known as reverse
cholesterol transport so that is why hdl
can pick up cholesterol from the
anthrogenic deposits and then it can
return it to the liver for recycling
purposes and that's why
hdl is certified as the good cholesterol
now once
ldl is produced in the liver it would be
utilized by several organs and that's
crucial we have seen that that's why
ldl is not bad
but too much of ldl is bad when ldl gets
deposited into arteries and other spaces
then it can cause harm otherwise ldl is
important
now
hdl
is a reservoir for apple lipoproteins
hdl can uptake honesty for unesterified
cholesterol hdl helps in esterification
of cholesterol as well and
hdl takes part in reverse cholesterol
transport that means picking up
cholesterol from any other places and
returning it back to the liver for
recycling purposes
that's why hdl is really good for our
body
now
hdl picks up cholesterol from this
particular anthrogenic plaque
where ldl has deposited excess amount of
cholesterol
ldl
hdl then move to the circulation and
return it into the liver
and this selective transfer is known as
the by the term reverse cholesterol
transport once it is inside the liver
the cholesterol can be
utilized to produce colic acid which
would be used to produce bile salt or
bile
that means the cholesterol is now
recycled or repurposed for another
production
so we can take a example to understand
this process better imagine these
garbage trucks are
illegal
so generally these garbage trucks go to
the dump yard and dump their garbage
so these
garbage trucks are ldl and your dump
beard is nothing but several organs like
adrenal gland or let's say your testis
so whenever they dump it in the dump
yard things get recycled repurposed and
things are produced from there right so
cholesterol is dumped into the testis
and it it is used to like produce
steroid hormones like testosterone
but problem occurs when this
this garbage depositing truck is
dumping the garbage in the roadside and
you can imagine these roads are actually
arteries
and when there is accumulation of
garbage that can cross cause problems
like that can increase the traffic or
etc similar thing happens in our artery
as well so it's a very sim uh important
metaphor to understand this process
overall the big risk for
increased ldl level is deposition of
excess cholesterol in the artery and
thereby narrowing the artery wall which
can constrict the blood flow this
increases the chances of heart attack
and that's pretty alarming right
now the biggest question is how to keep
ldl and ldl low and hdl high
if we avoid all type of oily processed
deep fried food then our ldl would be
automatically low instead we can
we can kind of have a healthy choice
like olive oil
healthy homemade food more salads
vegetables etc
in this way our ldl level could be low
whereas if we do daily exercises then
our hdl level would boost up
so all it matters for us is the ratio
between ldl and hdl so hdl should be
high and ldl should be low
anyway if
these
other things doesn't work dietary
modification or lifestyle modification
then doctors might prescribe medicines
which generally blocks the rate limiting
step of cholesterol biosynthesis process
and thereby reducing the level of ldl
cholesterol in the blood
let's talk about triglycerides which is
another thing
in your lipid profile test reports
now what does high triglyceride mean is
it good or bad so let's try to
understand this
so triglycerides are a compound which
are made up of glycerol and fatty acids
so basically they are esters of fatty
acids and glycerol
triglycerides might have
saturated fatty acids in their
fatty acid part or unsaturated fatty
acids as well
so
question is what does our body do with
the triglyceride
in general body produces triglyceride
and this triglyceride is kind of stored
in the adipose tissue for future
that means
it's kind of like a reserve for energy
in
in in terms of like a
future use so you can have triglycerides
stored for future and whenever your body
needs it can utilize that triglyceride
to generate energy they can also provide
cushion for your body and that is kind
of like in terms of fat in the adipose
tissue
now it's like your reserve money
you save it for now and you can use it
for different purposes right
like you can use your wallet to pay for
your drink shopping
movies other bills but when you have
excess amount of money even after all of
these things you would save it for the
future right
our body does the same when it has too
much of a triglyceride it save it for
the future
now
let me tell you that these kind of
stored triglyceride can be used
in times when our body is going through
stress like let's say starving whenever
body is going through starving no
nutrient is present in that time the
triglyceride is broken down from the
adipose tissue and it is channeled back
to the liver where fatty acids are
oxidized to generate atp and that atp
gets us going help us in all the
metabolic processes
now the particle which is highly
enriched in triglyceride is kylo micron
and vldl so chylomicron has 90 percent
of triglyceride whereas vldl has
60 of triglyceride so if you see in your
blood lipid test report if your vldl is
increased that means also its correlate
with your triglyceride level
now let's talk about
what really happens with these
kylomicron particle or vldl particle so
this gets uptaken by the adipose tissue
and
this is produced actually by liver so
this triglycerides can come from
food that we eat the fatty food the
processed
uh food that we get the cheesy ones
but also liver cell can produce
triglycerides by specific biochemical
process and that can be secreted in
terms of vldl and this vldl particle
is important and it also supplies
triglyceride to different body parts
now triglyceride biosynthesis happens
when you are very well fed when you eat
too much of sugar when you eat too much
of processed fat all of these cases
triglyceride synthesis can be triggered
but high triglyceride is again a big
problem
moderate level of triglyceride is good
but high triglyceride may contribute to
hardening of the artery wall and
ultimately called
arteriosclerosis
this increases the chance of restricted
blood flow and thereby heart attack
so this is
increasing the chances of stroke heart
attack and all the cardiac diseases
extremely high level of triglyceride can
also cause acute inflammation in the
pancreas and it can cause pancreatitis
question is how to interpret the lipid
report so there would be a normal
biological range provided and you have
to understand
where do your
test result fall for example in this
case the test result is 250 mg per
deciliter and that is
quite high right if it is beyond 200 we
can see from the reference values it is
high that means this individual needs
immense exercise or medically control
the triglyceride level
then let's talk about what are the cause
of high triglycerides
first of all
you eat more calories than you burn and
you don't have enough amount of exercise
in your daily routine
that can be a leading cause
also can conditions like obesity
drinking too much of alcohol
uncontrolled diabetes all of these can
lead to high level of triglyceride in
the blood
in addition to that
sedentary lifestyle
with consumption of
refined sugars can really increase your
triglyceride level
so sedentary lifestyle lack of exercise
food with refined sugar work life stress
all can add up to your increased
triglyceride in the lipid profile test
and ultimately it would risk your heart
risk your heart and it can increase the
risk of stroke and heart attack
so what are the ways to reduce
triglyceride
and
how to become
fit from a fat
so basically
exercise has no other alternatives to
reduce triglycerides when you do
exercise all of your triglyceride
reserves would be utilized and used up
by the body and thereby
the triglyceride amount would be reduced
daily 30 minute of
exercise is kind of
recommended by fda as well
exercising would help you to burn that
extra calorie
and
especially if you have a sedentary job
doing some exercise freehand exercise in
between work is highly recommended
other than that having healthy food and
avoiding unhealthy food would be a good
way to reduce both cholesterol and
triglyceride
and last but not the least
if you cut down the alcohol consumption
or if we kind of like modify the amount
of alcohol we take that can also cut
down our triglyceride level
recently intermittent fasting is quite
popular to reduce triglyceride level
because you are giving your body
artificial stress environment by not
eating for a certain window of time and
in that window if it is long enough your
reserves or your fat reserves would burn
and it would provide you energy during
your fasting regime and now intermittent
fasting is a really popular method by
which you can reduce your cholesterol
triglyceride etc without even doing any
kind of medications
so if you want to learn more about
intermittent fasting and the associated
health benefit you can click on the
video in the eye button also if you want
to learn about triglyceride in details
or apple hypoprotein in details all the
links are provided in the i button
now medications are available to reduce
serum triglycerides when exercise
doesn't work or the level is abnormally
high
immediate treatment is required and
these medications would actually block
the way
by which the tissue actually uptakes uh
try this right so in this video we're
not going to talk much about the
medication part but we kind of covered
the harmful effects of excess amount of
ldl and triglyceride in your blood so i
hope this video was useful if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe and
thanks do let me know in the comment
whether these videos are useful for you
thank you